how's it going everybody it's Warren
Happy New Year to everyone I hope
everybody had an awesome
New Year's Eve last night I hope
everyone was safe and I hope today is
just awesome for everybody hopefully
this year is great for you individually
and hopefully it's great as a community
and it's already started off with a bang
we have news about the Wanda vision
series being moved up from its original
release date yes it is coming out sooner
and I'll talk about why that may be in
this video the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway ended last night I'll be
posting the winners later on today so be
sure to check out my video later on
tonight but my xbox one or ps4 giveaway
continues it ends when I hit five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so all you have to do to enter that is
be subscribed with notifications turned
on like the video and comment down below
so this morning the official Twitter
account for Disney Plus sent out a tweet
that said is this not what 2020 vision
means question mark already a little pun
there with 2020 obviously this new year
and vision and it goes on to say from
hashtag Toy Story 4 and a lot into
hashtag Lizzie McGuire and Wanda vision
here's a look into our future at the
blockbusters and originals coming to
Disney Plus this year they played a
little promo and in the promo was the
Falcon in the Winter Soldier of course
that's scheduled to come out this year
but the Wanda vision series was in there
as well so we are getting the 1 division
series in 2020 this year super exciting
news this is one of the more anticipated
Disney Plus series and it's also said to
have a really big impact on the MCU and
other future MCU movies as well while no
official statement has come from Marvel
Studios we can pretty much put the
pieces together because we know what's
happening with other films and the
reason that this is most likely moved up
is because Marvel is going to announce
another movie or another show now Marvel
Studios has already officially announced
Miss Marvel she-hulk
and Moon Knight and it is possible that
Marvel is fast tracking the one division
series so they can release miss Marvel
she-hulk
and Moon Knight in 2021 and 2022 this is
possible since these movies have already
been announced and they're most likely
already scheduled but there is one movie
that is not scheduled yet that Marvel
could be trying to put in the MCU within
the next couple of years that could have
bumped Wan division up to 2020 and that
is Deadpool a Deadpool three movie or a
Deadpool reboot there's been a lot of
secrecy and a lot of questions about
Deadpool coming to the MCU however a lot
of hints about Deadpool 3 or this new
Deadpool reboot have been dropped and
recently in an interview Ryan Reynolds
has confirmed that Marvel Studios is
already working on Deadpool 3 and we're
just gonna call it Deadpool 3 for now
and maybe a Deadpool reboot but for ease
we're just gonna call it Deadpool 3 so
Ryan Reynolds has confirmed Deadpool 3
is already being worked on it's already
in development at Marvel Studios and his
whole team from Fox came over to Marvel
Studios as well which means they
probably already have a good idea of
what this movie's going to be and now
it's just the matter of working it out
with Kevin Feige but there's actually a
lot of evidence that suggests that this
has been going on for a very long time
now and that Deadpool is actually going
to be coming sooner than we think Ryan
Reynolds has actually dropped some hints
that Deadpool could be coming in phase 5
way back in July of this year Ryan
Reynolds did a Deadpool Instagram post
that said investigating heading into
year 5 or as I call it phase 5 the point
is I love conspiracy yarn hashtag leaked
/ siree so this is way back in July of
this year Ryan Reynolds's teasing
Deadpool in phase 5 and then in October
Ryan Reynolds posted a picture of him at
Marvel Studios so clearly work for
Deadpool 3 has been going on and this
was confirmed when Ryan Reynolds a few
days ago did confirm that Marvel Studios
is working on another Deadpool movie and
Deadpool and Deadpool 2 are two of the
most successful rated-r movies of all
time right up there with the Joker so it
would make sense that Marvel Studios
would make this a priority so we know
that Marvel Studios is most likely
moving the 1 division series up to 2020
because they're trying to work another
project in and it does kind of seem like
that movie or project that they're
trying to work in could be the next
Deadpool movie but regardless great news
the Wanda vision series is coming this
year so we don't have to wait much
longer for that let me know how excited
you are about this I know the Scarlet
Witch is many of yours favorite
superhero again happy New Year to
everybody be sure to look out for my
video later on tonight it's going to
announce the giveaway winners and I'm
going to talk a little bit about what's
to come for 2020 the Xbox one and ps4
giveaway continues all you have to do to
enter that
cried when notifications turned on I
like the video and leave a comment below
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof